alright guys bangbang super excited to
have Scott here thanks for doing us man
yeah thanks for having me let's just
jump right into your background before
we get into all the the fun art stuff
what would it be done yeah so my
background really is in technology so
starting different different technology
companies originally beginning with fin
tech and recently a founding masterworks
but maybe as interestingly for your
viewers is throughout that entire period
over the past 20 years I've also been
collecting art so to me historically are
it's just been a passion but I think
over the years really realized that it's
this interesting asset class which for
me personally has outperformed other
asset classes and has been a core part
of my portfolio so really the genesis my
master works was how do I take this
asset class that but I love or this this
market that I think is is really
interesting and just democratize it and
make it available to everyone
yeah what was like the fascination with
oradour how did you originally get into
just maybe not even buying or but just
being interested in it yeah you know the
real answer is that my mom was just a
mature artist and I grew up with art
books started collecting I think I
bought my first you know real painting
when I was 19 years old
kind of amid some early money the first
company that I started so it really
started as a passion and in the late
nineties at that point it wasn't you
know wasn't the asset class that is
today which is you know this this year
last year 68 million dollars in art soul
it's this large industry back you know I
would say it was was big but it was
really more of a kind of this really
passionate group of small collectors
that were really you know focused on
cultural significance of artists and
kind of the history of art more so that
the market dynamics today not it so I
gotta ask then you are in New York
Woodham what is your favorite art
gallery or museum then I always some
people who are at my favorite Museum and
it's been my favorite museum for is the
Frick Collection and which I don't know
if you've been to or not but I think
71st Street just you know it's a really
great museum and I can go and you can
see how some you know the beginning of
the 20th century and really incredible
art collection as well so I think that's
a great experience you know I don't know
if it's necessarily like favorite
collection in the world are they great
experience
yeah that is a fantastic when have you
ever been to the JP Morgan Library yeah
yeah that one's probably for me but very
similar type of type of thing all right
so let's first talk maybe about your
your art collection and kind of how
you've built it and was there rhyme and
reason and strategy or was it more of
let me just go and collect the art that
I actually enjoy looking at and like
throughout the years so I started
collecting what I would consider a brand
name house little artist like Picasso
but more you know B or C example
Picasso's was younger and then kind of
gravitating to colorful painting
minimalism and actually moved back to
Abstract Expressionism like this is a
John Chamberlain sculpture behind me
which was really the first time in
American history that artists started
heating in a non fear device artists
like Jackson Pollock Rothko still a war
net Newman the Chrysler and on Frankie
Fowler those those are one of the people
that exist in my personal collection
although the aren't necessarily the
artists that we focus on for master
works but that is that is what had been
collecting personal in for number of
years got it and then I guess part of
my interest in this entire market is
it's gonna be a week I mean told you yet
I was reading the book about Steve Cohen
I think it's called gray matter black
matter so whatever a black edge I think
is what's called and in it he's
basically buying a piece of art that you
know tens of millions of dollars and it
gets damaged as it's getting delivered
to him and I really kind of set me off
on this path of like wait a minute
there's pieces of art that are literally
trading at you know tens of millions of
dollars these are incredibly rare and
obviously sought after pieces and I
started just googling around and I was
blown away by only one how big the
market is but also to how many people
that you don't know participate in it
actually are either larger or collectors
themselves yeah now you can prevent a
goal five trillion dollars public
equities in the US I think her through
three trillion dollars it's an asset
class so most people aren't aware that
it exists simply because it's really
limited to to the the ultra wealthy at
this point yeah so maybe let's talk just
through it seems like there's two groups
of people the people who do it as a
hobby right they're doing it they're
collecting what they like and then
there's kind of the professional
investor how do you now that you've been
collecting for a while and actually
building a business in the space how do
you decipher between those two and kind
of do you try to look at those as
actually one group of just art
collectors or is it pretty separated in
the way that they approach are he buying
pieces yeah I guess the way I would
think about it is you know I it's
certainly I guess your approach to the
art market
matters and certainly obviously
determines returns but it's not
necessarily a requirement like if you if
you look at data published by a company
called order price our price is
basically constructed and
on the top with an artist for the past
20 years and that index alone just every
single painting created by every time an
artist has slightly outperformed for
probably today materially outperformed
the SP over that period of time so in
the art market in general is just really
taken off probably because our prices
are we believe that that our prices are
most likely correlated to global
cultural wealth creation so if you
believe that wealthy are getting
wealthier that you tend to believe that
our prices are going up over time yeah I
mean I guess that's intuitive when you
think of it through that lens right and
obviously that that is definitely
happening in the world it's pretty
compelling data on that front help me
understand how does the legacy art
market so before master work enters the
the kind of landscape how do these
pieces of art go from an artist creating
them to actually some sort of initial
purchase and then the secondary and you
know and third-order transactions that
actually make the market of art yes you
use the correct words as they're tuned
to two different segments of the art
markets they've got what is the primary
market and that just recently means
paintings that there's something for
their first time and then the other is
the secondary market which means
paintings they're selling to multiple
times so typically an artist is
represented by a gallery notice makes a
painting goes to galleries socials the
first section collector and then that
that painting gets resold thereafter
particularly as the is the artist market
grows where was that artists becomes
more popular we generally we really
invest where it's only focused in the
secondary market today you know there's
lots of amazing artists and primary
market there's lots of important artists
that are definitely investment-grade
we haven't focused on it as much just
because there's not as much data behind
it so it's difficult for a research team
to understand returns but you know
that's that's starting to think about
the market broadly got it and is there
segments of it in terms of you know I
can go to a local store and buy a 20
piece of 20 dollar piece of art and kind
of put a frame on it hang it up and
that's nice
then there's obviously the you know
fifty hundred million dollar pieces of
art that's a pretty big Delta there how
do you actually segment kind of the size
and maybe sophistication of the various
pieces or buyers yes so this is an
interesting stat if you if you look at
just the top 100 artists the top and
regardest constitutes 62 percent of the
overall art market which is 68 billion
dollars a year so I'm just thinking
about you know this from a total
probability perspective on being an
artist right there's I don't know
probably billions of artists that
existed historically and there's really
a very very very few number of people to
wind up kind of commanding the art
market overall so today when we when we
talk about the 60 million billion dollar
market we're really talking about
hundreds of artists that are there the
vast majority of that and then I guess
what puts somebody in that top 100 right
is it the value of the individual pieces
of art is it something that is less
quantitative and more kind of a story
behind the art how does that get
determined in today's probably different
than historically I would like to think
that value is correlated to what we call
cultural significance social
significance can probably be fined by
artists that institutions collect
artists that appear in other important
collectors collections
artists that that appear in shows with
other important artists there's
different ways to measure cultural
significance but you know in today's a
lot of a lot of values are just driven
by commercial dynamics that are driven
by kind of mega galleries that have a
lot of money the mode artists heavily
the chattering awareness and you know
the other thing that's really
interesting about the asset class I
think this is probably unique to our
dive I haven't thought of other asset
classes they're like this but you notice
Liz and creates so much work right so
many paintings and then eventually the
best way and then those paintings get
to institutions over time so it's one of
the few asset classes which declines in
terms of volume or supply and that
inherently dries up returns because of
scarcity so that's a that's a really
unique characteristic about art that I
think isn't totally appreciated by most
people and we see that we see them with
a lot of major artists and if you're
taking artists like Jackson Pollock I
think today there's there's something
like 23 drip paintings and private
collections most of those paintings are
not even one what anyone would consider
a painting right there meetings or see
paintings but this will sell for three
million dollars because there's nothing
else left so that that's really that's a
really unique character study about the
asset class and do those not get
replaced over time like those artists
get replaced by new artists like how
does that mechanism of as an artist kind
of ages out of the market basically and
they've got it now a finite set of work
is there not an increasing demand
because it's just more artists or is it
just that individual artist is finite
and that's what drives the value of that
specific collection this is one of the
first questions that our that our
research team study a couple years ago
and I think it's a it's a critical it's
a critical thing to understand about the
art market so the example that I like to
use of new collectors is if you buy a
Rembrandt today do you think that will
appreciate faster or slower than buying
you know an artist like Picasso and the
thing you see in the deed on the art
market which is is as interesting is
that the appreciation tends to follow
recency but in very white increments
meaning art created in the 70s and 80s
for example is appreciating at much
faster rates that are created most World
War two in are created in the 19th
century or were cars like Rembrandt is
now appreciation has totally stopped
meaning that if you buy over and grab
for ten million dollars today selling
twenty years from now you'll probably
sell them for ten million dollars plus
inflation so it is important to collect
artists you know
today's one I would say artist that that
our post-world War two our most most
compelling and most most interesting
there's there some exceptions for that
but generally speaking you know if the
artists artists in the last 60 years or
are probably the most investable got it
and then how does an artist you know
let's say take one of the top 100
artists they create a piece of work how
does that original price and that
primary sale where does that price get
set do they go out to kind of a small
group of investors or purchasers that
they know and and there's a price
determined there is the artists that
kind of so much demand that they can
just set their price and just take it or
leave it
the price times the price is even the
same yeah it's super interesting and
then I guess the secondary market is
more kind of market dynamics where it's
just where do buyer and sellers meet
yeah that's right and the way to think
about three auction houses in the u.s.
Christie's some the B's in Phillips and
those auction houses you know they're on
forever like Sotheby's so recently going
private was the oldest company in the
New York Stock Exchange of 275 years old
right so this is an asset class which
literally has betrayed a publicly at
auction for hundreds of years so one of
the things that fascinates us about it
is you have one of the the oldest data
sets on performance of an asset class
there is which which gives our research
team ability to really analyze data from
from long periods of time by different
segments the market periods etc it's
super fascinating and then I guess is
there any data that you guys have seen
in terms of that legacy art market
because it's been hard for individuals
who are not ultra wealthy to participate
especially at the higher end of the art
market is it one of these things where
you know the top 1% of
collectors or investors own 90% of the
yard or 20% like how do you think about
that yeah under collectors that you know
that I guess control but there's there's
a small number of people that have 100
million dollar-plus collections that are
actively training paintings in and out
of the art market
ya know you know there's different ways
to think about that too like a lot of
people think about that it's you know
there's a thousand people that control
sixty eight billion dollar market so one
way to look at and the other way to look
at it is was a thousand people that are
sort of like mini companies on their own
they're buying and trading these
paintings
it's scale so I'm assuming that the
thousand top people are incredibly
sophisticated do they have teams and
they're like very data-driven on this or
is it a I walk in I see a piece I like
you tell me it's thirty million I do a
little negotiating and we settle on a
price yeah I mean incredibly
sophisticated they're people like you
venture like Steve : right like they're
very smart successful people generally
because because they have to be in order
to buy art like this but I would say
that Dena in generally our market has
really suffered historically when when
we started masterworks one of the very
first things we did was we went out and
we purchased auction catalogs from I
think the 1960s through present and we
kind of team of 25 interns
actually digitized individual paintings
whether versus four and then sold for
public play and post that data on our
website so investors can access it
Angela shocking it may be you have a
market this big where something has
never been digitized like everything in
our world is digitized that the art
market is just you know kind of behind
everything else I would say sure sure
and then as you kind of got into art and
got more sophisticated about it at what
point did you have the idea for master
works and kind of what was that original
idea of the genesis - hey I actually
want to blown a company here yeah I
would say that was really that was
really
and that the blockchain stuff was was
was and you know we were thinking about
different blockchain ideas I think we
didn't you know then we didn't totally
fully appreciate the regulatory dynamics
with with what we're doing today and
we've now lined up with fifty-three
fifty-four thousand people on the
platform you know every offering about
the SEC are socially regulated but FINRA
nor a highly regulated business so we
initially thought of the concept is kind
of quick and dirty started by the
elephant which evolved into something
more complicated that was that was the
genesis got it and then kind of
explained today what that value
proposition is so i come in i create an
account what can I do and why would I do
that yeah you come to the masterworks
website today
create an account called their
membership team we like to speak to
every single investor that is interested
in investing on the platform and then
basically our offerings are investment
vehicles our single painting vehicles we
show you a particular training we tell
you what the store returns are of that
particular painting we have a risk
creating associated with the painting
you can read a full offering circular in
the pancreas and learn how you read an
s-1 for a company going public like uber
you can read it s1 equivalents what's
called a 1 a 4 for painting painting
calligraphy to securitize with us so we
give you lots of information on the
artist the market that returns the risk
and you can make a case-by-case decision
on whether you you want to invest in
those offerings and then just recently
we're really excited about a trading
platform that we announced I think
roughly a month ago so it's in beta we
have one painting on it next few weeks
we're rolling out more and more
paintings so people can conserve trading
securities and paintings so we've really
taken an asset class which historically
is you know the only way to allocate to
is you have 10 million dollars by
painting and we've secured as has that
so anyone can invest in these paintings
and trade securities in its paintings so
I guess there's a whole bunch of
questions in
here but when I buy into an offering
right so just say it's a Picasso it's
ten million dollars I put in some amount
of money how do you determine how much
money is like the minimum buying and
then is there a maximum in terms of how
much of that 10 million piece I can own
yes we'd like to talk to our investors
to understand how they're busting today
what their risk tolerances are kind of
educate them on different segments the
art market different risk profiles and
then try to figure out what the right
allocation is for them to an overall
portfolio and that's the approach we've
taken mainly because we just very
quickly learned that obviously nobody
knows how to think about it must take an
art so we try to provide some some
advice through through that process got
it and then obviously if I buy it's
called a hundred thousand dollars worth
of a ten million dollar Picasso I don't
get a hang the Picasso in my house where
is that peas kind of stored and kind of
you know is there any other components
that people should think through you
know working with artists foundations
now in the States to collaborate with
them kind of have them dictate where
they've planted paintings to be
displayed long-term so whether that's a
retrospective one of the offerings we
did the retrospective or just you know
local institution that the artist cares
about ideally we would do to hang his
paintings throughout the world where
members and master works can go and see
them and you know we don't have to keep
it at storage got it and then at any
point would you actually like put them
into some sort of art gallery and
there's like a cash flow component to
lending it out to these people or is it
really just the appreciation of the
value of the piece of art is where the
return draw is driven from yeah we do
have a gallery in Soho the
we operate where investors can come to
the painting zone you do that's their
obviously insatiable that's not
happening right now but hopeful it will
happen you consume but the way I would
thinking about investing in art is it's
really just capital appreciation there's
theoretical ideas on how you can read
paintings out and do different things to
generate income but that the majority of
the money is just just made for
principle appreciation got it and then
you mentioned kind of the secondary
trading function of the actual shares so
if I buy kind of a fractional ownership
of a piece of art I'm assuming that
historically because there hasn't been
the fractional ownership there hasn't
really been kind of any sort of market
there sounds like you guys are actually
building that now and the hope is that
that'll be a liquid market where people
can go ahead and actually get liquidity
after some holding period maybe a sweet
so we have trading now that's active for
for one painting next week so we're
definitely seeing a ton of interest
around investors setting up trading
accounts and really trading shares
between each other it's a release they
don't think about long term but we we
fundamentally believe that from a
product perspective you need to build
out the trading platform to give people
in the community because you know for
most investors waiting three to seven
years for paying the sell is just a
longer longer allocation and so yeah
things are for further business got it
and then I guess part of the mechanism
here is if I'm buying fractional
ownership into a piece of art or you
guys going and buying the piece of art
and then turn around and securitizing it
or do you kind of pseudo securitize it
almost like an SP deed to then go
acquire it like what's the sequential
mechanism there yeah so we you know
based on how the art market works to
really get quality I guess quality
paintings that we think have potential
for good returns we really to buy those
paintings that balance you capital so we
go out and buy the painting with our own
money we Turner
we you know put it into an LLC you filed
with the SEC and then mr. telling chairs
and then and our management fees are
similar to a hedge fund that we are more
than a half percent per year plus 20% of
profit on a painting sells so it's
that's how I refuse got it and then how
do you think about our I know that it's
outperformed the S&P since 2000 which is
pretty impressive right kind of a
two-decade type you know data set there
but how does it perform differ in the
good time first the bad times right
we're kind of in this economic crisis or
liquidity crisis right now do you guys
see better or worse or maybe just the
same type of performance in these
economic downturns that's what we did we
did a a research study with Citigroup of
2019 a correlation so correlation
between our and other asset class
because most investors really care about
the correlation between R and s P
generally speaking orders an
uncorrelated asset class so it's close
to 0 for all other asset classes and
part of the reason because it takes you
know take a step back thinking about
that is because it's just global asset
class which is not country specific you
can carry a painting across borders it's
really owned by the ultra-wealthy
and there's the scarcity dynamic where
important artists bodies work or
constantly declining for the reasons we
talked about before so that just that
just causes it to behave differently
than most other asset classes so the
correlation factor specifically between
art and ESP is I think we conclude as
0.1 3 so basically zero and then if you
pressure test that during different
financial crises sort of what you see is
during 2000 the art market increase in
value
2008-2009 it had the highest correlation
ever kbsp which is roughly two point
four point five decline half as much as
the S&P declined interestingly at 2016
the art market declined when the S&P
increased in value
our best guess it our best guess as to
why that was most likely brexit capital
controls going into place in China and
then now you know it's too early to tell
what we think during the the current the
current corona crisis it will likely be
it correlated so it just it just behaves
differently yeah and I guess is there a
geographic difference like do you see
maybe kind of price arbitrage based on
geographies or you mentioned capital
controls obviously would definitely
affect it like anything else you see on
a geography by geography basis and we
definitely see last 20 years you
definitely see this influx of ultra
wealthy countries coming into the dark
market right China today is a huge
player in the art market roughly clearly
mark the market overall whereas ten
years ago there was close to zero you
know Russia I came in a big way now it's
kind of gone with was sort of the old
guard dynamic its he do you know his
country's build up this populations of
people that are all too well they did
you sort of see that impact the art
market overall the u.s. is now roughly
twenty five percent of the market and
then I guess like how much of the
platform you guys have built right so
take somebody like me who probably has
much more interest in art than expertise
in art obviously you mentioned kind of
having a team be able to talk to the
customers or the users of the platform
and kind of get educated but there's
nothing like that experience is there
other things that you either see users
on the platform doing or things that you
guys are doing in terms of just helping
people I guess get up kind of learning
curve and really just a void you know
the classic mistakes in the market yes
we have you know we have a feature on
the website which is is unlocked as soon
as someone invests our price database
and that basically gives you all of our
return data by artists market that our
research team uses to - I guess inform
our purchasing decisions
we have roughly 40 artists that we're
focused on this year or just saying and
all of that that decision was driven by
data from our research team on which
artists markets are accelerating most
quickly so we expose the data to
investors to learn about the market I
think fundamentally believe the more
data we give people a little more
training and get people the more engaged
they become so that is that is part of I
guess how we think about this process
yeah and you mentioned earlier kind of
the digitization of art nothing you were
specifically talking about a lot of the
data and the information right but the
art still being physical and either a
painting a sculpture whatever have you
guys seen any interest from the legacy
art market in kind of digital art so
actual not physical art but but it being
represented digitally in any way today I
think from a commercial perspective we
still haven't really seen it but there's
obviously lots of people focused on that
yeah because it feels to me like part of
the beauty like the sculpture you know
you have behind you like being able to
physically see it in full three
dimensions and walk around it is a big
piece of the value rather than you know
you can I guess somehow make it 3d on a
screen but it's just not the same thing
as being able to you know actually enjoy
got it and then I guess what are the
lessons learned that you've had since
you started the platform right so you
kind of go into it you've got this idea
of hey we're gonna create more access
for people or democratize access to this
market you obviously came at it with a
ton of expertise and experience anything
that either one surprised you as you've
gone down this path or or or lessons
learned I think I think we expected
there would be more demand from our
investors where they call household
brand a blue-chip artists artists like
Picasso and what we've really seen is
there's actually a pretty smart
from from our investor base for when we
would define as middle a career living
artists so you know probably half of our
acquisitions now really focus on artists
like Banksy or cause or Cecily Brown or
you know how these cats and some of
these people that are that are really
well-known names in the art market but
maybe aren't necessarily a Picasso and I
guess just thinking out loud is some of
that Germans to take Banksy for example
one the type of art that's done right I
think is very attractive to kind of
maybe younger people or a certain
generation too a lot of the ways I think
people come across Banksy is through the
virality online right whether it's you
know the stunt type stuff or just
pictures being taken to being shared
online and then I'm assuming that
there's a certain demographic that's
naturally drawn to a technology product
that you know you guys have built do you
think that is kind of driving that
interest in a very certain subset of the
artists or do you think it's an
overgeneralization you look at a
particular historical return and then to
is risk category so for a lot of these
blue chip artists that are legacy
artists like Picasso we would risk
create that artist in a meaning our
lowest risk rating but the returns would
probably be 10% of Sorek returns whereas
someone that can Banksy that these
aren't these aren't exact numbers but we
would we would risk rate a be and his
historical return might be 15 or 16
percent so I think what we've seen is as
people are more naturally gravitated to
those higher returns and willing to take
more risk to to to achieve them and I
guess like artists like that how many of
them in your experience are aware of
maybe the financialization of the market
versus they're just making things that
they think are cool or they want to make
and are more kind of creative and
expressive yeah
I'm from friends a lot of these artists
you know some of them are are aware of
master works and I would say they follow
two different cams so there you know one
camp doesn't like the idea of are being
viewed as this this financial asset
class the other camp likes the idea of
art being democratized so they don't
only have to sell paintings to the
ultra-wealthy
so you know the reaction is different in
the other person
I could definitely see that with on it
without a doubt
and then I guess from a technology
standpoint you mentioned initially kind
of looking at blockchain ideas and
technology today the platform has some
of that still incorporated or have you
been kind of gravitated towards a non
blockchain technology stack and then
kind of a more traditional regulatory
type framework and we really just
because the regulatory overhead for the
business we've really had to move away
from you know we haven't frankly seeing
acceptance by the sec concepts we were
actually if we don't get our very first
SEC filing I guess it'd be two years ago
now I think we were the very first
company ever to have some Hwacheon
concepts qualified in our offering but
the regular it
I think environment is kind of worried
and more difficult rather than busted we
think that is a fairly popular viewpoint
that you have but but I mean look part
of it too is there's learning right like
they have an incredibly difficult job
already and they start throwing new
technology and I'm all these different
things and they make sense but it sounds
like you guys have been able to navigate
that without having to use the
blockchain technology and can you know
can offer that liquidity people yeah
which historically has been viewed as
you know a little bit of an insider's
game and I do think kind of SEC
qualification of these offerings has
added just a little bit of transparency
or trust to two masterclasses people
otherwise skeptical of for sure and the
last question on the art side is just
the legacy art market change or how do
you think it will change as things like
fractional ownership and kind of the
digitization of the data and some of the
market what does that impact look like
on kind of that legacy art market of
institutions that just because
institutional capital etc we tend to
share that so you know I I fundamentally
believe that if you can allocate 3% of
every investment portfolio to art it's
an integer item you're dumping trillions
and trillions of dollars into our
markets so we think this is a really
interesting opportunity to take an asset
class which is nordley has been limited
the ultra-wealthy
just storms they hasn't been investable
but has outperformed other asset classes
is uncorrelated and therefore a good
diversifier to any portfolio and making
it festival by everyone so everyone can
done part of it that's that's what's
really exciting so we you know in that
scenario you could see a world where
asset prices increases just because of
it more there's more capital inflows
yeah it's really interesting I think to
kind of think through almost in some way
that digitization makes it a more market
expanding
there's market expansion and I guess
would you then say it's not only an
increase in accessibility for a kind of
socioeconomics basis but also on a
geographic basis like now I don't have
to actually have physical access to the
piece I can be anywhere in the world and
gain financial exposure
[Music]
and and I do think that having more
capital to the market makes it easier to
support more artists at every stage of
their career yeah super interesting I
and each interview asking people what
their favorite book is where the most
important book you've ever read would
that be for michael Porter's competitive
strategy that's that's one book that
I've taken every business out of her hat
and trikes you've run it through the
five forces framework so that's
definitely the most emotional why does
that one stick out to you you know I
think I think I started my career really
focusing mainly on execution right so
working really hard you know trying to
get things done you know the fastest
first market except Drive and I think
wait plugin force I took me years to
realize is that you know if you're
working really hard the wrong thing it
doesn't matter so you got you you wanna
you want to choose the right thing to
work really really hard at first so yeah
I mean that that is just a great
framework for thinking about
differentiation right how do you
differentiate a business and make it as
easy as possible to avoid competition
and capture market share over time and I
think a lot of our you know on the
businesses I start over by businesses of
work cliff rotate that are from that
that's an awesome I definitely agree and
working on the wrong thing that's
probably not a good idea where can
people go find you online or find out
more about masterworks okay we can get
you started
awesome and listen I appreciate you
giving us the crash course I feel like
art is one of these things that a lot of
people appreciate looking at but they've
got no clue about the business behind it
I learned some today and hopefully as
well yeah thanks for having me